foreign
Diane in Charlotte hey Diane what's
happening
um not a whole lot John I am really
honored to uh get to speak to you today
you too it's an honor for me to talk to
you thank you so much for for calling
and trusting me so what's up
some um issues uh within my marriage uh
I had a son as I came into this marriage
he was young at the time
um under the age of five and
um I married my husband uh things were
good of course in the beginning
um
I don't really know where it came in but
there was some trauma that started um I
felt like some uh emotional abuse uh
towards me and my son but mainly my son
um and so we we've suffered through for
about 10 years now I I love my husband
I'm walking beside him we're separated
but I'm still walking beside him
um as he starts counseling and we try to
move forward the problem though is my
son he uh just seems to wallow in that
resentment
um and how he's been done for the last
few years and I'm trying to get him into
counseling and I just wanted your
thoughts on uh helping push him that way
because obviously right now I mean he's
he's 15 and he's you know I'm not doing
that yeah I mean I don't yeah I totally
get that I don't blame him
um
does he have a relationship with his
birth dad
he does he
he's done with good
um healthy men relationships because I I
didn't think or I didn't feel like his
dad was going to be the father that I
wanted for him anyway but also I'm gonna
I'm gonna be mean is that okay that's
okay okay
you surrounded him with healthy men but
you also kept me in an emotionally
abusive parent such a step parent
situation for a decade
yes sir
so you get there's a mixed signal there
right I do
I do
um
no there's not there's not so we're here
now
um but
stepping back we have to paint a picture
of what this 15 year old boy is has been
through what where you say he's full of
resentment is he resentful at you for
leaving is he resentful for it taking so
long as you resentful for this old man
being so
psychologically abusive to him what's he
resentful about
there what took so long what did take so
long
just understanding
um
what my position needed to be I mean I
had a child that I was Raising with him
now with him now meeting my husband and
um
I just
I
don't
know
it was hard
um I
I had mixed signals coming from family
his family would say they could see you
know the differences he showed and and
the way he did but yet they couldn't
step up and say something
um because he's a man and you know he's
leading his household I guess that's I I
just called bullcrap on that they didn't
say anything because they're cowards
that's the truth
none of this leading my household
nonsense that's just garbage you can't
that's just that's just excuse for
Generations people let men just run over
their families and their kids and their
wives because of that kind of nonsense
that's just that's cowardice it's just
pure cowardice
um
laughs
so let me give you a picture of what's
in this 15 year old kid's head and I
only know because I've met with a
bajillion of them over the years okay
because Dad left him his birth dad left
him
whether these are facts or not this is
what's in this 15 year old kid's head
then another man came into his life
her mom said she loved
and that guy
did everything he could to isolate him
and put him out on the side and treat
him like garbage
for a decade
and so in many ways that that Dad that
another man left him too
but I want you to I'm saying this to not
shame you I want you to try to get
inside the head of the 15 year old
because it's going to play an important
role in how we can walk out of this
thing okay
that 15 year old has been putting puzzle
pieces together for a long time whether
it's true or not and the puzzle that has
your 15 year old has put together is mom
loved that abusive stepdad more than me
yeah she cared more about that and their
new kid they had together than my safety
and my well-being
and now she wants to me to get better
because I'm not okay nah I'm not buying
that see what I'm saying yeah that's
what's in his mind right now
and more importantly than what's in his
mind that's what's in his body pulsing
through his veins through his blood
and by the way you're still sticking
with this guy
and I'm not saying it's wrong and I'm
not saying loneliness is evil and
economics issues I get it man I get it I
get it hard
I'm just trying to to relay this picture
Through The Eyes of a 15 year old just
who's trying to navigate his world
and find out where do I fall and who is
actually on my team
that makes sense
it does
um and then he gets a chore then he's
looked at as you're the problem 15 year
old you're acting out you're not paying
attention in school you need to go get
these things
and he's like dude I'm just a kid this
world happened to me
all right yeah
here's the path forward well I I just
threw a lot at you
and maybe no one's put it that bluntly
for you before tell me what you're
feeling what you're thinking you can
tell me I'm full of crap that's not hurt
my feeling
no I've I've been listening to you for
quite a few years and or ever how long
and
um I I felt like that's the things that
you would say
um
you didn't even have to call
I put myself uh with better help um last
year to try to navigate uh this
separation and
um got us into counseling last year
um we've quit the marriage counseling
um I actually quit better help uh and
went with the counselor that we started
with and then he's picked up my husband
that he has picked up his own counselor
and we're trying to navigate you know
trying to figure out you know how we
move forward here's how you here's there
cannot be any moving forward
until that man
comes to your 15 year old son and takes
a literal knee
and says I failed you
we could get into the psychological
abuse that sounds like a whole other
phone call but the way I talk to you the
way I isolated you the way I drank too
much around you the way I talk to your
mother
as a man that your mom brought into your
life to model what masculinity looks
like and what love looks like and what
fatherhood looks like I freaking failed
you
and I'm sorry
and then you join him
and say I let this go on too long and
I'm your mom
and if one person on the planet had to
have your best interest at heart it was
me
and I'm sorry
and everything's gonna be different from
this point forward absent that
you can do all the work you want it's
not going to compute in the mind of a 15
year old boy that feels like every
single person in his life who's supposed
to care about him bailed on him
foreign
and any sort of growth and adjustment
and therapy and all that you can talk
about it all day long either your ex or
whoever you're married to whatever your
relationship status is of this guy you
don't talk about all day long that's
fine
um that's not going to compute
it's about action it's about what are
you doing that's different
this young man has said every adult in
his life let him down
foreign
to step up and say I love you and I'm
sorry and this is what this is going to
look like moving forward and he's going
to get some years to heal
and by the way the greatest gift you can
give him after an apology is that you
heal and that your ex or separated
husband whoever heals and to get him to
quote unquote go to counseling you can't
afford them you can he's gonna sit there
and have a stare off like Good Will
Hunting you could
after you and your ex or whatever your
husband's name is you all apologize
you could say
we want to learn how to heal and we want
to learn how to say we're sorry and we
want to learn some better parenting
techniques for you we want to learn how
to love you better
would you be willing to come to these
sessions with us
so that your voice can be represented in
how we can better love you because we
have absolutely let you down and you
deserved more from that and you didn't
get it up until now
we're owning that and now we're going to
change everything
that's your invitation if he gets an I
mean that's what you do to get him to go
to counseling is you invite him to come
be a part of helping teach you and the
other guy
what love actually looks like and feels
like but parenting actually a little bit
loves and looks and feels like
that's that's the path forward Diane
that's the path forward
love your kid enough
love your son enough
and step dad if you're watching
take all that tough guy energy and all
that
take a knee and tell that 15 year old
little boy you're sorry
and that this psychological abuse ends
now
and then as I say all the time
he gonna watch you
way more than he listens to you
the proof will be not in how much
therapy you go to and how much books you
read it'll be how you treat that little
boy
your move